I can't think of anything more
heartbreaking than to lose a child and I
know many will approve of the decision
to scrap fees for funerals for the four
thousand or so deaths of children under
18 in England every year after all
funerals as anyone who has ever
organised one those costs thousands of
pounds which is ludicrous and
unaffordable for many the government has
therefore launched the children's
funeral fund in the next budget to spare
all bereaved parents funeral costs on
top of the pain of losing their child
sorry
but I can't see why this is necessary or
even right the welfare state looks after
us from cradle to grave but I don't
think that this should literally mean
parents should pass the bill to the
taxpayer for the sad duty of laying
their children to rest unless of course
they really cannot afford to pay I'd far
prefer to see funeral costs come down to
sensible levels than the state reaching
into private grief well I thought you
were doing this topic Rachel I just
thought perhaps there was a mistake I am
surprised that you picked this one thing
Margaret Thatcher in law lor II has
always been remembered for his snatching
milk from the children right so a piece
of perhaps career political advice never
take things away from children now these
are parents who are grieving that their
children were taking money from parents
yes it's a right your that the
government wants to grant to two
families if their child dies I can tell
you a story and it really touched me
it's a recent story happened within the
last month and it's tragic it's it's
it's really you know nobody wants to go
through this and I went to school to
pick up my two-year-old boy from nursery
and I was handed a letter it folded and
I thought perhaps my two-year-old was in
trouble I thought why they giving me a
letter you know I got a bit scared of it
was it was he done something wrong I
open the thing and it apologizes and
begins by explaining why two of these
teachers aren't present what happened
was that one was a the mother and the
other was the sister so an auntie and a
mother working in the same school their
15 year old boy had been stabbed to
death and so they they were they were
absent from school and the letter was
just to inform the parents and I felt it
was so sad because I thought they were
looking after my son and they'd lost
their own son and it was it was terrible
to read it was I felt heartbroken for
the rest of the day but then he got
worse
because then these parents the mother
was reduced to sending out a GoFundMe
campaign pleading with the parents to
help fund her child's funeral who was
only 15 right young black family in the
part of London that you'd associated
with knife crime he was stabbed to death
it's you know it's tragedy upon tragedy
now the cost of that funeral they look
the average cost of funerals in London
6,500 pounds my main point now these
families now they're already grieving
right they're already looking after
other people's children while their
child has been taken from them in this
way and they had to beg people to send
them money to help pay for that you know
and that's a level of indignity frankly
I don't care that it's the course it's
indeed heaped on pain and agony and in
this planet my point do you know the
it's up to 2,000 per so it's not by the
way I'd pay the whole damn thing if that
family I think the government should pay
the whole damn thing limited so it's up
to two sounds like your father christmas
when the children die but you don't want
to other don't you who are living to get
your money up to you know hold on so
would you what's being complete control
of the funeral industry there there is a
fund available for the indigent if they
cannot afford funeral costs already what
I think you did start it took me in the
sphere of government expenditure of
around drinks a round of drinks when
they can find a billion pounds to do a
deal with the DB and if it helps people
at the worst time of their life
absolutely no and I'm normally that
tightest it could be on government's
video I immediately see the sentimental
force of having a chin jerk children's
funeral front
my point about this is is that the
government cannot be there to stand in
whenever something anything goes wrong
or is painful taking certain people
sighs we have a Social Care crisis we
have all people dying I think my view is
basically I think there should be a
means testing to avoid anything like the
situation might've just described which
we have because that avoid paperwork at
all cost of avoid anything like we just
described to all cost but as a matter
principle the reason why I think the NHS
is the most beloved thing in this
country is because it's that thing that
says that we all care enough about each
other that we will all make sure tip-in
enough to make sure that everybody is
okay at the time of deepest and darkest
why means that we don't means test
children in hospital but I means test
I'm saying I'm saying that somebody
who's literally a billionaire if that
money could also could have been sent to
save another another child yeah but you
can apply that to the NHS as well right
so if their insurer in the Children's
Ward but their parents are billionaires
then charge the moment at the end of the
day this is a health issue it comes
under the remit of grief illness and
death and I just think that does
actually prop up highly inflated costs
therefore you depress on this show and
I'm just wondering why actually the
Conservatives are promising to end
austerity and you come along not even a
Tory and you want to make people pay for
the death of their own children it's
there are so many things that we could
ask the state to pay for Michele yeah I
think it's a brave topic actually and I
think that you know luckily and
thankfully the numbers are reasonably
small because niche does depict that
actually it's children burying their
parents and thankfully it's not often
that it's the opposite way around but
I've had that situation as is not a
secret in my family where my parents did
have to bury my sister their child and
it was a horrendous experience but it's
an experience nonetheless so when you
organize a funeral it is an unfortunate
by-product that you have to
in a period of crisis and hurt you have
to deal with formalities now I think
that actually the costs of funerals they
have gotten out of control and I think
that the whole funeral market now is a
business sector is ripe for disruption
and the costs are spiraling because of
limited limited competition etc but do I
think that it is the responsibility of
the state - for example if I make it
personal to have paid for my sister's
funeral I don't I think that what could
happen is the state could exert
influence where it can so for example
why our councils constantly raising the
cost of burial sites I would be pushing
back on that why our councils charging
for some of the things like listing
deaths of children so there are things
that the government can influence on a
point of cost I mean for the people on
the lowest incomes in the country a
funeral cost takes 40 percent of their
annual out go I want to explain what
it's like if you walk in my final point
is don't forget these companies they're
doing it for profit-making purposes so
what you're doing is you're the
government is basically creating a
profit for a coupie so what I would like
you know I'm not arguing against profit
I would make me need you while I'm
arguing against is that the government
doesn't need to be making to be paying
that profit because what I'm saying is
where is that sense of community if a
family why did that lady that you refer
to it why is organized my two brothers
and my mother my mother moderately
recently the council take is minuscule
it's the Undertaker's it's the hearse
it's not just goes into thousands if
you're carrying will not attend to
reduce their costs and for children make
sure you want the state to control what
private enterprise does oh no what I
want is common sense and decency in
society can also change depending
the two aren't contradictory you can if
a child dies the state can step in as a
benefit to those families while trying
to encourage more competition the
funeral market you you don't have to do
either/or